[Musique]
il nous sommes maintenant en
conversation avec monsieur gérard picard
qui se trouve à saint paul trois
châteaux 7 en france
je pense que c'est dans le sud de la
france mais si je dis ça je verrai
avignon bon ben ça va bien alors
j'imagine que vous allez quitter le
travail parce qu'on vous appelle au
travail en ce moment et à la fin du
travail vous allez allez allez au
bistrot n'est ce pas peut-être pas tout
de suite j'ai d'abord rentrer chez moi
et fibre ans parce que vous nous avez
envoyé une question sur les bistrots des
ist un os
alors quelle est cette question alors je
ne suis quand même pas mal de français
qui ont émigré
est ce qu'un bistrot ça une terrain sont
même terrasse un bistrot où il peut y
avoir un bistrot s'intéresse à l'origine
du mot bistrot c'est pas canadien ça je
peux vous dire ça non ces russes
[Musique]
c'est votre origine du mot bistrot mais
vous savez que cette origine et les nous
la version qu'on a trouvé pour vous
c'est qu'il s'agirait d'un régionalisme
importé à paris au xixème siècle bistrot
proviendrait du mot poidevin et non
russes mais ça pourrait aussi être de du
sud la région vous habitez il ya un mot
apparemment c'est bistroquet bistroquet
q uot t et ça signifie à l'origine un
domestique région la même chose on a sur
la région non ne retire pas en janvier
1964 c'est l'art au canada où je
pourrais dire que l'on a ouvert un des
premiers bistrots au canada
ça existe pas vraiment chez nous les
bistrots en fait il ne viendrait pas à
l'idée ici un canadien français que ce
soit au nouveau brunswick où québec ou
en alberta chez les franco albertain de
dire je vais aller au bistrot pas une
expression grand à ce moment là en 1964
il ya même une équipe de télévision de
radio canada qui a trouvé ça tellement
intrigant cette idée d'un portait donc
le bistro français à montréal qu'on
s'est rendu au bistrot chez loulou et je
vais vous proposer d'écouter un extrait
de ce reportage de 1964 pourquoi bientôt
chez loulou pensez vous qu'on ya chez
doudou parce qu on y rencontre des gens
très agréables et aussi peut-être un peu
originaux différent des autres mais
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve des gens comme
vous beaucoup de gens de cinéma de la
radio
est ce que vous venez souvent au bistrot
oui de temps en temps ça veut dire
combien de soi par semaine ou par des
diplômes parce que je travaille très
souvent dans une boîte à côté et entre
les spectacles je viens là où en
attendant l'heure de
je travaille chez claire est un bon
qu'est-ce que vous faites comme
travaille d'abord chanté et qu'est ce
qui vous avait donné l'idée de fond
d'une boîte semblables j'ai travaillé
très longtemps à paris dans un bistrot
et dans ce genre de boulot je me suis
toujours dit à ses jours on va voir
suffisamment de liberté et la ville de
montréal avec ayant un caractère
français
il sera certainement possible de montrer
quelque chose de typiquement parisien
[Musique]
élargissons maintenant la conversation à
des notions plus familière aux canadiens
est ce que vous avez chez vous des
tavernes est-ce que vous avez chez vous
des brasseries oui une brasserie pour
vous ce serait quoi on va manger chez
nous une brasserie c'est un restaurant
c'est d'abord un restaurant où on sert
des boissons alcoolisées et les
brasseries ont toujours l'avantagé
d'offrir un service continu donc c'est
pas l'endroit où vous allez le soir
seulement voilà ces deux bases chez vous
ce serait du ragoût de pattes de cochon
chez nous ce serait de pâté chinois
souvent chez nous des plats typiques
genre sokoto aux ragots de haut chez
nous ce qui prend la place publique du
bistrot c'est davantage les tavernes thé
anglais rn11 nom avec lequel vous êtes
sans doute très familier de la bière
c'est vrai que le mot taverne sehili
d'origine anglaise d'angleterre à
l'origine c'était là le lieu où on
donnait à manger en échange d'un peu de
peu d'argent ce n'était pas le grand
luxe là c'est en fait un ancien terme de
marine c'était une chambre ou un
officier marinier
on est là dans les vaisseaux ou là les
16ème 17ème siècle et c'était l'endroit
où on vendait aux matelots des vivres
des boissons du tabac les produits
voilà c'est un endroit plutôt pour les
services essentiels pour mettre l'eau
alors quand on va aller boire on va les
prendre un verre sont pas les obama ont
peu à l'est la taverne
si jamais vous venez à montréal
l'invitation est ouverte et les sincères
il faut m'appeler et on ira prendre un
verre au bar d'accord mais par là moi je
vous emmènerai pas parce qu'il n'y en a
pas deux depuis de très sympathique mais
par contre je vous emmènerai et on fera
le tour des caravanes quoi missionné en
plein côtes-du-rhône donc
y'a moyen de goûter des vins bonnes
conditions d'un bon dieu merci beaucoup
gérant puis on sort palmer est bientôt
aller à travailler tôt
[Musique]